magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman welcome
everybody i want to start with something
a little different today uh a judge has
rejected a plea deal for the killers of
a mod arberry
which would have seen them spend a lot
of their sentences
in the much less
severe conditions of federal custody
rather than state prison and this is
really interesting because it relates to
the way in which
hate crime laws and sometimes really
serious crimes
can end up with people having an easier
time serving their sentences now but
before we even get in getting into the
details i want to preface this by saying
i'm very much against the idea
that there should be
punishment above and beyond what's
actually prescribed like one thing is we
can talk about sentencing guidelines
should you get x number of years or y
number of years if convicted of certain
crimes but as an example
oftentimes there are some even in my own
audience who sort of take pleasure at
the idea that those convicted of sexual
assault and particular child sexual
assault will receive punishment in
prison
from other prisoners in terms of
violence and even rape above and beyond
the sentence for me that's a failure of
our prison system if our prison system
can't even keep people safe from other
inmates that's a failure it's not
something that i say they're really
going to get what's coming to them
because they're also going to be
attacked or raped in prison so that that
i find that to be completely out of
bounds and really an indictment of our
prison system but
without a doubt
in general
inmates would rather spend time in
federal custody rather than state prison
the conditions generally speaking are
considered to be much less harsh and
severe and that came close to happening
with ahmad r berry's killers so let's
look at this report from cnn a federal
judge monday rejected the plea deal
reached by prosecutors and travis
mcmichael on hate crimes charges so
remember that they were convicted in
georgia travis mcmichael were talking
about here convicted in georgia on state
crimes and then there was also a federal
case that is still in process which
includes hate crime charges the
agreement would have precluded his
federal trial in the killing of a mod
arbory earlier mcmichael had agreed to
plead guilty to a single hate crime
charge interference with rights in
exchange for prosecutors recommending he
serve 30 years in federal prison
under the agreement the 36 year old
mcmichael would have been transferred
from a state prison to federal custody
after completing the federal sentence he
would have been returned to georgia to
finish life in prison without parole
five of the final years would have
counted towards his supervised release
from federal prison u.s district judge
lisa godby wood said she was not
comfortable with these guidelines and
arbory's family also opposed the deal
the judge has been expected to rule sep
had been expected to rule separately on
the same plea deal for gregory mcmichael
but after the judge rejected travis's
deal attorneys for both mcmichaels asked
for more time to decide whether to
change their pleas to guilty the hearing
is next friday the family also was
against this idea
arbory's mother wanda cooper jones was
outraged by the proposal and felt
betrayed by u.s justice department
lawyers she told a state court judge
to give the mike mcmichaels what they
deserve life in prison and urged would
not to accept the deal quote please
listen to me granting these men their
preferred conditions of confinement
would defeat me it gives them one last
chance to spit in my face after
murdering their son and as as it says
here um these are often called country
clubs these federal prisons they have
better funding they're quote generally
more accommodating um this is one of
those cases where
you
and we have to see what ultimately
happens this deal has been rejected we
have to see until something is accepted
we we need to wait before we really
comment this is sort of the opposite of
what hate crimes are supposed hate crime
laws are supposed to do
they did a worse crime
it was motivated by racial hate racial
animus racism one might say and for them
to end up doing easier time in federal
prison defeats the point of these hate
crime laws now your reaction might be
david this is why hate crime laws don't
make sense that's a different argument
and i do believe that when there is
a motivation for a crime that goes above
and beyond the individual but rather to
their membership in a certain group or
class be it based on race or national
origin or
ethnicity or whatever the case may be of
sexual orientation
there is something more insidious about
that because it's a crime not only
against the individual but it's a
warning
to others who were members of that group
if their membership in the group was a
factor in the crime so for for me the
issue here is not that hate crime laws
exist although i know some in my
audience disagree with me
but this is an issue
of very specific negotiations where
first you've got the state trial and you
have a verdict and you have a sentence
and then later to say wow this crime is
so bad that there's also a federal case
but the federal case actually leads to a
less severe punishment that seems
backwards and so i'm glad that the judge
rejected this plea deal it wouldn't make
sense to say your crime is so bad that
we're also charging you federally but
you're going to get to do 30 years in a
country club rather than in state prison
i'm all for reforming state prison i'm
all for reforming sentencing guidelines
all of it but when the crime is so
serious that you have state and federal
charges you shouldn't end up with a less
severe punishment
thanks to having a federal case so we're
going to continue
watching it and we'll see ultimately
what is accepted i'm curious to hear
from you about this one
we have seen over the last four years
decade 15 years
almost pic pick your time frame
um much of the american right wing
riddled with projection projection where
they claim the left is doing that which
they are actually doing so one example
is the right loves to say we are for
free speech and the left is against free
speech and in reality it's often the
truth that the right is for free speech
only in their very narrow view
for as long as it's convenient to them
and then they are very quickly against
it they don't care about free speech
once it's no longer convenient to them
social media regulation is a great
example of this as soon as the lion's
share of coveted disinformation is
coming from the right they're no longer
okay letting twitter or youtube or
facebook decide what's okay on their
platform they want to
mandate that these platforms allow covet
disinformation now on the other side of
that they claim to be against business
regulation they're that's a principle we
are against regulating businesses until
twitter is banning the people they want
to ban from twitter and all of a sudden
they say we need to regulate twitter to
force them to allow certain speech you
guys understand this concept the
principle is abandoned as soon as it's
inconvenient so along these lines
there's this topic of of books and
banning books and they claim the left
wants to ban books that are inconvenient
to them uh that being said i've heard
nothing about wanting to ban bobby
kennedy jr's anti-vaccine anti-doctor
fauci book
or whatever other book what what we want
and speaking for myself
i want
to educate people
so they never fall for buying these dumb
books in the first place but this is not
about me
because now there's a rash of right
wingers
wanting to ban and in some cases
succeeding at banning all sorts of books
from all over the place often under the
guise of protecting kids that's the
explanation that they will often give
a few examples of this a tennessee
school board has voted unanimously to
ban the pulitzer prize-winning book
mouse this is about the holocaust in
cartoon form some of you emailed me
about this they want to ban it from
their eighth grade curriculum they say
it has objectionable language and nudity
cartoon nudity of course and there's
similar campaigns underway in all sorts
of other
districts in more than 30 states at this
point stateline has been investigating
this and they will often say these books
are pornographic
merely because they depict an lgbtq
experience sometimes a black character
with an lgbtq experience uh huffington
post huff post now it's called reports
that in texas the republican governor
greg abbott
is
sort of taking advantage of this effort
to pull quote pornographic or obscene
books from school libraries after
republican representative matt krauss
circulated a list of 800 books that he
believes crosses the line and the vast
majority of these books were written by
women or people of color or lgbtq
writers according to the dallas morning
news so consider how many of their own
supposed principles they are violating
here they are for free speech
but they've got a long list of books
that they want to ban
they are for doing what's best for
people yet they're not letting education
experts the teachers decide is this book
a good teaching tool for my students or
not
they are deciding from above the elected
officials that is and the reasons that
they give for banning most of these
books
should actually apply to the bible but
of course the bible is always okay uh
murder in the bible incest genocide
sexual content it's all in the bible but
the bible is beyond reproach that's a
sacred cow
so putting all of this aside
a great way to get kids interested in a
lot of these books is to ban them i mean
i i'm against the book banning on
principle of course
but i also recognize that banning these
books might get kids interested in in
the books as well
the urge to do something you're not
supposed to do
can sort of end up being like an adrenal
adrenaline rush but that being said
many of these books can easily be read
online but it is again an example of it
it's really one of the major stories of
conservatives it's not even conservatism
of reactionary right thinking of the
last era of this era which is our prince
nothing is more important than our
principles of course our principles are
sacred
until the outcome of those principles is
inconvenient when it comes to speech
when it comes to censorship when it
comes to regulation when it comes to
elections at the end of the day and this
is just the latest example let me know
if this is going on in your state in
your locality you can find me on twitter
at d pacman
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily funded by viewers and
listeners like you people who watch
clips on youtube or listen to the
podcast listen on our various radio
affiliates or even watch on free speech
tv you can sign up and get a membership
cheap very cheap
at joinpacman.com you can also use the
coupon code wow22
to get a discount if you please not
means tested available to everybody sign
up at joinpacman.com
all right so we had two correspondents
at the trump rally over the weekend in
conroe texas we had luke beasley down
there and we had josh pitt and these
guys did a fantastic job we're going to
look at some of these videos now
this is the worst of the worst of what
we suspected was going on at these
rallies in terms of the people i put
together some questions for luke and
josh you can find by the way if you go
to youtube and search for luke beasley
luke has a youtube channel uh make sure
to subscribe he's really doing a great
job uh so let's start i mean let's just
jump right into it
um the first guy that luke spoke to
um admitted to going to the capitol on
january 6 2021
i
plain and simple let's just jump right
into it and
account for the fact that there's a
there's background noise it was a wild
and raucous situation uh some of the
audio is not perfect but the guys did
the best job they could here is one guy
saying i was at the capitol on january
6th so you're here on the trump rally
[Music]
2 million patriots now of course there
were not first of all i would argue that
they're not patriots but that putting
that aside there were not too many
million people in washington on january
6. that's widely known now
and i'm happy to be here i walk about
three miles to get to this field imagine
walking three miles to go to a trump
rally dang tell me you didn't go from
the rally capital the lieutenant
governor of texas
oh my goodness yeah that's crazy no it
was uh it was a it was a great day until
the end
for sure
so there is a guy who admits that he
went to the capitol um two of the
questions that i told the guys we should
really ask are ask people what they
think about critical race theory
and then if they say they're whatever
they say about it then ask them what is
critical race theory i also told them to
ask about socialism
it's basically as good as we could have
imagined um they're very much against
critical race theory
and they don't know what it is here's
josh pitt
talking to the first guy and again i
know there's background audio we
i think we can still make out what's
being said here the questions are
what do you think about critical race
theory what is critical race theory
think about critical race theory
what is
what do you think of critical race
theory i'm not a fan
what is critical race theory not what
i'm a fan of none of them know what it
is shouldn't surprise us here's another
one gotcha are you concerned with
critical race i think absolutely it's
gotta go
it can be taught huh no yeah it is being
taught in some some schools some schools
are fighting it so it's not there yet
but i can guarantee you around the
united states it's in schools at a very
young age and it's very sad
so it's terrible that it's being taught
including to kids at a young age
it will change this whole country what
is critical risk what is critical risk
theory criteria is a lot of things i've
not done a lot of research on it but
there's a lot of things in it
the uh total race-baiting
teachings the uh helping out by the uh
algae require i can't even say examples
lgb qua that's interesting i have never
heard
critical race theory be called lgb qua
but i mean listen uh this this is
someone who is very much against it
yeah they're teaching sex education to
the kids i mean there's just all kinds
of stuff now sex education has nothing
to do with critical race theory but i'm
sure you guys know that
with it i'm not good on that because i
can't like give it but yes okay um then
there were a lot of people
this is something huh a lot of people
furious with mike pence um and in fact
we are now looking at a guy holding a
sign that says execute pence for treason
uh let's listen a little bit here
he could have stopped it
[Music]
he couldn't stop it that's what
the fraudulent call me
but i know that according to the
connection
to be executed in the public square so
what just happened is this guy is
holding a sign that says execute pence
and then another guy yells that clinton
should be executed in a public square
this law and order people
don't care about due process go figure
are you okay
[Music]
so now we move on to
my next question which is is joe biden a
socialist or communist and i made sure
that the guys know if they say yes
you've got to ask what are the socialist
or communist policies and again it's
exactly what we expected
he needs to be in prison
sorry or hung like back in the day but
you know that that rule has kind of
changed
oh sorry and we need to we need to
actually move up to the uh so the
communism part is just a few a moment
ahead here uh okay here we go finding my
there's just so much here
so do you think joe biden is communist
yes
yes
yes he's so up in the china is not even
funny so based on what policy that he
supports would you consider to be
communist
what do you mean say that
isn't that the best on the basis of
which policy is joe biden a communist
sorry what do you mean
well it's kind of the key question ma'am
are there any policies that he's enacted
or supported
well he supports china and that just
sums it all up right there
okay so the china president
not the chinese people that are being
brutalized in her gotcha he supports the
chinese he spends in their pockets and
that's not going to change so this woman
thinks biden's a communist because he
supports china communist china i believe
so so this now we've got another guy and
if you're not watching this guy is
wearing full trump regalia it's a trump
hat
a trump jersey
a trump cape
and a trump flag and here's this guy's
explanation as to why biden is a
communist
a week
we
wake up
to be against uh communists you know we
fight for america
for american citizens
american fools
okay um
then we asked people are they vaccinated
um most of them were not
[Music]
want my immune system and i'll fast make
that even stronger i didn't know that
you could fast to to to do something
about covid not eating
to deal with covet is i've not heard
that before
absolutely not and my son's not and
oh and then lastly
we go back to this guy who explains why
global warming isn't real and he's
talking about something related to
planets
section right so
so
big obvious
each season the earth fight
travel in the universe uh
one one four of the full circle so each
region in the universe is different
right and how do you change that
you got to pray to god i guess what he's
saying is there's no global warming
because
earth is moving through
the universe
and
climate changes as a result and all you
can really do to control it i guess is
pray pray to god so
as bad as anything we imagined
a major success great job by luke
beasley and josh pitt and great job by
producer pat putting all of that
together and we're going to do that
again we'll keep sending people to these
rallies and
your memberships help pay for us being
able to do that we'll let you know when
the next rally is upcoming
well guys for better or for worse
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me uh it's hard to
think of a bigger endorsement than alex
jones thinking what i'm doing is very
bad
alex jones devoting a
a 12-minute segment to me now four
minutes was him selling some kind of
vitamin
so we're not gonna look at that but at
least eight minutes devoted to me
making me out to be a predator of some
kind
let's just jump right into this thing
this is truly beyond belief
let's take a look
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you he thinks pac-man never talked
to the new world order pac-man never got
tried to get hired by the kiss of your
group because pac-man's a loser is it
isn't this the absolute best thing i
mean it's it's wild
he's a sellout he's not a real man
and remember who did i sell out to they
never tell me
he's not a knight at the round table
that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate he didn't actually
have a real discussion with the power
structure he worships see i said no to
the evil power structure
not because i was a hero because i had
god i had a connection to the infant and
i knew this was a failure this was not
good i didn't join with god and justice
because i was a good person i did it
because i had discernment and wanted to
be with god
and the still images of me to so that i
that are supposed to i guess be ominous
are pretty funny sam cedar texted me let
me tell you exactly what sam's comment
about this was so funny um
he said it's really weird he does a
close-up of your face and tries to make
you seem evil but no offense you look
like a teenager from the neighborhood
who would carry an old lady's groceries
for her home from the supermarket and
yet and yet i'm made out to to look very
evil now what's really funny is i don't
even know why this clip triggered alex
jones so much it was one of the
voicemails i played where people were
saying
do you think if things got bad you'd be
able to get out of the country for some
reason it really triggered alex jones
so this is just a
snapshot of the bizarreness of acting
like a tape call is a call
and then nodding with it and talking to
it because you're so scared to actually
talk to people
now understand what alex jones is saying
he's saying
i'm when you guys know we do a voicemail
on every show when i do a voicemail i
say it's a voicemail i'm not pretending
it's a real call so alex jones is lying
to you that might come as a shock
he also says i don't take live calls on
the show we take a dozen live calls
every single week you i mean you guys
all know that we take live calls all the
time so the entire premise here is a lie
and give them the power of being live
we do it all the time that's what the
left always claims jones has fake
callers
jones has fake reviews because they're
fake because they rig everything because
they're so scared they gotta control it
all
we we've been taking live calls every
week for a decade
and then to here because we can show you
the raspberries and poll okay so um then
he continues going into this stuff and
then he goes back to the personal
attacks which i have to tell you i find
them funnier than anything else
so they're doing this to us classical
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny collapsing and then he's
talking about them as victims talk about
talk about a fantasy talk about a
simulation he's in his own but he knows
it's not a simulation he loves this for
his little groveling followers that
actually drink this kool-aid oh that's
an attack on you guys he's talking about
you guys continue
yes
uh but maybe some people in the audience
uh have a different perspective on the
bonus show today
we will talk about the fight that's
enough oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad
there is no greater endorsement for the
bonus show than alex jones hating it
guys i can't think of a better
endorsement of everything we're doing
then the fact that alex jones hates it i
really can't
if i was telling my children who not to
be it's that guy i mean he's a disgrace
and i don't say that like god i feel
good about myself no he makes me feel
pathetic oh well that's interesting
that's uh i mean we should alex if if
seeing me makes him feel pathetic
that would be something to explore in
psychotherapy i think that that would i
think
psychoanalysis would have a lot to say
about that
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
so anyway that this is basically just an
unbelievable thing now a couple a couple
really funny things about this number
one i only got two messages in response
to this
that's how diminished alex jones is
right now in the past if when he was on
real platforms
and he would do like a set you know
eight minute attack video it would
create a frenzy i got two messages
because
i don't know that anyone's watching alex
jones anymore secondly
i bet alex jones has no memory of the
fact that he and i
have met in person and we talked for
close to a half hour
at the talker's new media seminar some
years ago alex jones me and the hosts of
free talk live ian freeman and mark edge
ian now i believe is is
under arrest um the four of us just had
a completely normal conversation about
the business of media
and
i'm sure he doesn't even remember that
but at the time he wasn't acting like i
gave off predator vibes
he seemed fine chatting with me
and uh i'm sure if you it probably made
no impression on him i mean listen who
was i to alex jones at the time but uh
just an interesting interesting little
tidbit but
an incredible endorsement when alex
jones is this upset with you
uh you know you know
that uh you must be doing something that
is resonating with at least some people
so there it is
um alex jones very unhappy with me we'll
have clips from this on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
you can also find the clip on my
instagram at david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
david pepper who's the former chair of
the ohio democratic party teaches
election law at university of cincinnati
law school and is also author of the
book laboratories of autocracy a wake-up
call from behind the lines it's really
great having you on david
thank you it's good to be with you so uh
yeah i think maybe to to start with
there's so many different places where
we could look and talk about autocracy
authoritarian tendencies and beyond
sometimes people talk about voter
disenfranchisement and suppression
techniques at the state level we
obviously have this big national story
of the multi-pronged effort to take an
election that they didn't actually win
in november of 2020. there's all these
different things a control of school
curricula i mean when you look at
autocracy what are the most concerning
kind of bullet points that you start
with
so i'd say my biggest concern is that we
focus on some of the most prominent
people like trump and and we should
but my biggest worry is the other side
that has you know some of the players
have been at this for a long time
and while we focus on the high profile
people and the things that make a lot of
noise and the bright shiny objects like
barger taylor green
they're focused on the institutions
that either support democracy or if
weakened
could usher in you know the lack of
democracy or ultimately something that i
think is referred to often as
competitive autocracy
and the reason i wrote the book is to
say you know it's it reminds me of the
movie don't look up which i was at first
afraid to watch but then glad i did it's
saying don't only look at washington the
institutions that shape our democracy in
so many ways are states
one side figured that out a long time
ago they have a minority view that can
only survive in a world without robust
democracy so they've had their eye and
tentacles on the states for a long time
and they're converting them into as i
described laboratories of autocracy
that are non-stop undermining
key you know principles and tenants and
protections for democracy
and it's accelerating and so it's sort
of look at the institutions
don't just look at our usual politics
which is you know federal majorities one
through swing districts and swing states
look at the institutions that shape
democracy those are largely state houses
yes the federal government can do
important things to protect against
those they must but the heart of it is
at the state level and i just think one
side has been blind to that for a
generation the other side has been
focused on it like a laser and are
scoring victory after victory because of
that
so competitive autocracy competitive
authoritarianism that's a term i've used
with my audience before this this is
important to understand this is that you
have at least i say in theory but maybe
some people would say in principle
democratic institutions and electoral
competition but it's not really fair
competition is is that generally the
gist of it yeah it's it's it's
rigging things in advance
it's minority rule locked in
with a veneer of legitimacy with the
with the illusion that everything was
fair and up for grabs and you know it it
sounds very sort of um that's that's
quite an accusation
but
we know where what it looks like it
looks like hungary and so we make this
accusation
it's not really rebuttable anymore
because they're all going to hungary
celebrating it in the wide open you know
tucker carlson cpac trump you know
endorsing orbon they're not hiding that
the competitive autocracy system
that that you know we see in other
countries is that what they want when
they embrace hungary and as i as i go
through the book
almost every element that hungary is
going through rigging legislative
elections suppressing votes in the
opposition party attacking courts almost
every element that hungry you know go
through the checklist is going through
you could overlay into state house after
state house in our country it's the same
pattern so it's not like they're only
celebrating it in 2022
it's either they've been modeling off of
it or just doing the same thing on their
own for years and so yeah it's it is
what it is the model and that's why i
think
one of the reasons i wrote the book is
not simply to say here the elements of
it we should be concerned about
but we have to move away from doing
things that unintentionally legitimize
it all
and when we're too silent
when we
when we treat it as politics as normal
by applying the by allowing the
filibuster to stop us from stopping it
by
treating it like any other issue we play
into
the you know the competitive autocracy
end goal which is not only to to sort of
suppress democracy but to make everyone
think that it's it actually still is
there in in a viable way so right that's
the key point right because if they need
to seem legitimate if people believe
it's legitimate they are less likely to
rise up against it
correct and it sustains for much longer
you know again what is not an effective
competitive autocracy storming a
building that was not what you do that
was literally i'm sure orban was like um
no that that does not look legitimate
the key to my success is not
openly you know trying to overturn an
election
it's actually just subtly
predetermined outcomes
everyone votes and you wipe your hand to
say hey look election happened i won
again for the tenth time even though i'm
in the minority so so that's why i think
we you know
it and some may not like this but that's
why i thought it was good when those
texas legislators left texas
they were declaring this illegitimate
you don't normally leave your state i
wouldn't recommend that but if something
is so illegitimate that if you just sit
there and vote no and it passes the
voters may think well that's just
politics is normal it's reaching a point
where i think a people who are fighting
for democracy have to call this out and
that's why
to me the senate needs to keep amping it
up joe biden can't go silent again um if
if we if we have to force chuck grassley
and
uh josh hawley and cruz to debate for
two weeks on end to stop our votes to
protect democracy great make them do it
because competitive autocracy relies
on a sense that it's legitimate and
normal we know it's not but i think too
rarely do we actually act in that way
which is allowing it to continue so one
of the um discussions that i often have
with people who watch my show with other
guests or whoever really is
to what extent do you focus on changing
the system versus using the system
to our advantage and the prototypical
example is the the gerrymandering
redistricting which is right obviously
i would rather and many of the people in
my audience would rather assist them to
prevent gerrymandering to begin with
whether it's a nonpartisan redistricting
commission whatever whatever the way it
is you prevent the problem but until
that happens is there any choice but to
take every opportunity to gerrymander
for your side because otherwise they're
going to gerrymander how do you strike
this balance and is this is it a great
question
yeah i mean gerrymandering is bad no
matter what it i try and show in the
book and i go through you know so my
book one way to think about it i do hope
everyone gets it because
no interview can sort of get into the
details sure and and my i wrote it to be
read and shared because i'm so alarmed
but i it's think of my book as sort of
what's the matter with kansas with a lot
of focus on ohio but the point is about
democracy itself and i walk through that
once you have the non-democratic world
of gerrymandering where no one's
accountable and this is going to be true
for anyone who does it although they do
a lot worse than we do this is not a
both sides issue
public outcomes crater
in these non-democratic rigged state
houses because the incentives that we
normally expect on politicians and
democracy good public outcomes don't be
corrupt all the account all the
incentives that come with the
accountability democracy disappear in
these rigged systems so ohio under this
terribly rigged non-democratic state
house
has seen our educate our public
education fail our health care outcomes
in the low 40s highest level student
debt in the country so no one should be
stuck in a state house with no democracy
it's just bad but to your point
there's going to be a natural race to
the bottom if one side sees one doing it
especially on the congressional level
and if they don't do it then they lose
power and this is why
it doesn't have to be either or this is
why the federal legislation that would
provide guard rails for everybody is so
important and i want everything there to
pass but but the legislation in the
freedom the vote act would basically
come up with some rules
about what an unconstitutional
gerrymanderer looks like
i'm sorry or an illegal gerrymander in
the federal law uh may not be deemed
unconstitutional but it could be deemed
illegal
that would basically say whether
whatever state you are there are certain
rules you have to follow you're
violating the law and the congress has
the right to do that that's the best way
to avoid what you talked about change
the system add guard rails and don't put
any state in a position
that that it's creating basically a lack
of democracy and all the terrible
results that come and by the way
we in ohio we did pass two
constitutional amendments
uh we elected a fair supreme court we
showed in the last couple weeks that a
court will uphold fair rules
if if you have them in place and that's
why the court struck down a really bad
map here that's a win for democracy the
best in the last generation ohio but it
shows that that federal legislation
could do the same thing so there's a way
to avoid that that terrible choice by
establishing rules that everyone has to
follow
many in our audience understand and uh
are aware of the push to privatization
that exists in a number of different
areas in in society in the book you talk
about how a lot of that is actually
happening thanks to state legislatures
can you give a couple examples of that
because i think oftentimes the
assumption is that it's happening as as
a result of things that politicians in
washington dc are doing
no the so the the big private players
have figured out over the last 20 years
to get the worst hairiest most unpopular
and most inconsistent with public
outcomes
parts of their agenda done
you go to the state houses that's where
you do it because no one's paying
attention
these people are rigged so they can
never lose their election even when we
do really stupid and honorable things
and so examples of that in ohio
they drain public schools of funding for
a generation to give it to for-profit
charter school
online outfits some of which have been
total scams
and
the politicians even though the schools
in their own backyards are plummeting
and have less money
and the public and the and the private
players they've helped who've given them
money the whole time have literally
turned into scandals
they've only won because of it they've
never lost so that's a great example you
know in ohio we've been draining money
we the state house has been pulling
money out of local governments for a
decade to give it out as tax cuts at the
high end the entire trickle-down theory
is in play in almost every state again
it would not be sustainable the shape of
small towns and school districts is
collapsing it wouldn't be sustainable in
a normal democracy because the results
are indefensible but in this rigged
world where they can't lose these
players have figured out
you couldn't get it done in washington
it's too hard but in and again get
coverage in a way that that would be a
problem right
but that betsy devos agenda
a state house will do it without
thinking twice and for the most part no
one even knows
there are examples all over the country
in in one of my advice pieces of advice
in my book to anyone running
don't talk about most of what we're
talking about right now in your
30-second general election ad
find the public outcome that is the most
horrific
in kansas it was the fact that they had
school four days a week right and laura
kelly won on that issue she could have
said anything in the world about kris
kobach did a lot of democrats might have
said we agree but she was smart enough
to say the true issue where i can
explain the impact of this corruption
and this privatization of everything at
the state level and how it impacts
public outcomes people care about the
best example of school four days a week
in texas
it's an energy grid collapsing so that
people froze to death a year ago and
beta o'rourke is doing a great job on
that focusing on that it's we have to
translate
the the corrosion of the public asset
public good and the common good is
endemic to these broken privatized state
houses and we have to be smart enough to
not just you know
run around saying the sky is falling
although it arguably is falling quickly
is to say
the reason you everyday voters should
care about this is your town and your
school and your roads and everything
else are in worse shape because the koch
brothers have essentially taken over
your state house
in the um in the just minute we have
left other than registering to vote and
voting in every election where you can
vote
what are the what's the low-hanging
fruit that people in the audience should
be doing uh it's it's go broader and
then registering although that's a very
important part of it in states like
georgia and ohio think about your
footprint that you have of influence and
think about all the ways that you can
use that footprint to lift democracy and
it's bigger than you imagine if you're
on the board of a homeless shelter is
the homeless shelter engaging those it
serves or a food bank do you know the
mayor of a town are they registering
voters in their rec centers in their
libraries
scale it up if you run a small business
is part of your mission of that business
lift democracy and again it's
registration it's engagement once people
are registered it's early vote just
think
literally sit down and write down what's
my footprint and i go through all the
details in the book and and
engage that footprint as much as you can
to lift democracy and that includes
helping people run for state office
state house office board of education
you name it registering but use your
footprint don't wait for stacey abrams
to save the day or michelle obama don't
just assume people are going to get
registered the bureau of motor vehicles
use the things you do every day to also
lift democracy
and that's the way i think we start
hitting a scale especially when we know
that every single day the other side is
attacking those same voters and
attacking democracy so if you're not
doing this stuff
we're not just
holding steady we're losing ground in a
lot of these states without a doubt uh
the book is laboratories of autocracy a
wake-up call from behind the lines we've
been speaking with the book's author
david pepper
david really appreciate your time today
thank you great talking to you thanks
for all you talk about every day
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
show there's some super interesting new
polling that i want to talk about about
the 2024 election and specifically about
what republicans are thinking and the
bottom line is donald trump's support is
rapidly collapsing among republicans who
ultimately will decide is donald trump
the 2024 republican nominee or is it
going to be someone else now
we have seen already in january two
pretty sizable rallies and every
indication that donald trump is going to
continue doing more of them in march
he'll be speaking at the
republican national committee meeting
some kind of mini convention or event in
new orleans louisiana this is a guy who
wants to be involved in 2022 and he
wants to use 2022 as a way to ultimately
have the option to be the nominee in
2024 if he so chooses up until now we've
basically been saying
the 2024 nomination is trump's for the
taking if he wants it
it's now a question mark and we're going
to look at some recent data which shows
at least some republicans seem to be
getting sick of the guy and this is a
very very different situation when one
where it's trump's if he wants it the
associated press reporting trump facing
legal and political headwinds as he eyes
a comeback and it references that video
we showed you last week where trump
referred to himself on the golf course
as the 45th and 47th president sort of
alluding to a 2024 run uh and the
article points out his popularity among
republicans is declining somewhat with
71 percent saying they have a favorable
opinion of trump compared to 78 in
september but the new poll shows only a
narrow majority of republicans 56
percent want him to run for president in
2024. the poll found 44 do not want him
to run
this is a very different situation to
what we had throughout most of 2021
particularly the first part of the year
56 to 44
among republicans
want him to run that's basically 50 50.
now of course
that's still fine for winning the
primary in the sense that if 56 of
republicans support trump and the other
44 percent support a bunch of other
people some ron desantis some whoever
right mitt romney jeb bush trump still
wins with that but these are
dramatically lower numbers than we
previously had another interesting
article in the washington post do
republicans love donald trump as they
once did
which writes his support within the
party
may not be quite as robust as it once
was
and that is based on a lot of the same
polling this one though references a
washington post university of maryland
survey completed at the end of last year
found that more than six in ten
republicans say
there is evidence of widespread voter
fraud nearly six and ten say biden's
election was not legitimate
more republicans say they want trump to
run again in 2024
than they say want another candidate but
the margins as we talked about
50 uh down to 54 to 46 and then lastly
there is a marquette university poll
just looking at favorable versus
unfavorable on trump
and if you look now uh
you see that
trump's favorability
is down to only 32 percent
67 percent now have an unfavorable
opinion of donald trump only 32 have a
favorable opinion of trump so there is
going to be a real question here as to
whether this guy is actually viable this
is great news now i don't want to praise
republicans for this you know i saw some
commentaries online saying republicans
are finally coming to their senses no
they're not
uh republicans are much the same as
donald trump or it's what have i heard
about recently and because donald trump
has been sort of out of the public
spotlight for some period of time
i think this is mostly an artifact of
that if there's no real
uh alternative appealing alternative to
trump
i think it's completely reasonable and
even likely
that donald trump will be back before
you know it and and popular but there's
a very interesting kind of uh
intermediate period here
where if trump's role in the 22 midterms
is seeing more as a nuisance rather than
an advantage and if some trumpist
candidates lose in 22 which is just nine
months from now at this point
and some new republicans not at all
connected to trump win
it may just move the republican party
into saying i don't know i think we're
just kind of beyond trump there's
nothing moral here where the republicans
have said we cannot allow this again
that was really bad it was bad for the
country it was bad for the world it was
embarrassing this is not about that this
is just a sort of what have you done for
me lately top of mind type thing and i
think some republicans are just kind of
like oh yeah trump that guy
uh i don't really know that i want him
to run again and as we saw even from the
people we talked to at the trump rally
in conroe texas over the weekend
it's not that these are reasonable
republicans it's that they just seem to
be thinking maybe it's time for somebody
else so we're going to keep watching
these numbers really closely but this is
a significant shift away from trump at
least in recent polling
dozens of you wrote to me
about the neo-nazis
openly demonstrating in florida in
orlando florida it is absolutely wild
what is going on down there and it's
another reminder that you know it's it
it pains me that among some
on the left
uh jews are seen as a privileged group
that is not a minority
targeted by so many different
right-wing and sometimes unfortunately
left-wingers as well
but we should not allow that to become
the dominant perspective among the left
because it is just flat out wrong
as officials denounce nazi rallies in
orlando
desantis accuses political opponents
of smear what
neo-nazi demonstrators in orlando over
the weekend drew bipartisan
condemnations but governor ron desantis
remained silent until monday afternoon
when he responded to questions about the
rallies with a tirade
against his political enemies rather
than against the neo-nazis
so what i'm going to say is these people
these democrats who are trying to use
this some type of political issue to try
to smear me as if i had something to do
with that we're not playing their game
well what about denouncing the neo-nazis
he referred to the demonstrators a group
of about 20 shouting anti-semitic slurs
while waving nazi flags
as some jackasses doing this on the
street and said they would be held
accountable
but he also accused democrats who called
for him to denounce the neo-nazis of
exploiting the demonstrations now they
just want you to denounce the neo-nazis
it's very simple here's some video
um of this
bizarre and disgusting event
[Music]
so that was hale hitler and what he did
it can be hard to hear and if you're not
watching there's swastikas everywhere
they're doing the um hail hitler salute
as well they're dressed in sort of like
um
man is it is it sort of like ss larping
uh
i i don't know
white power shout there
six million viewers
so six million viewers referring to six
million jews dead in the holocaust and
doing the heil hitler salute
white pride is when you think it white
power is when you live it that's another
nice little
phrase how close your eyes are together
so i think that wow uh that was
your we can tell you're a jew from how
close together your eyes are
you effing k
i'm gonna go tell somebody
[Applause]
this is the s states folks this is the
united states and this is not only
demonstrations i think it's important
that we remember
that this is the sort of
cartoonish outburst of it
but that we are continuing to see
stories like this one out of chicago
synagogues vandalized and damaged hours
apart in west rogers park and
lincolnwood multiple synagogues
vandalized or damaged just miles apart
sunday in chicago and lincolnwood
someone spray-painted graffiti on a
synagogue in west devon
video shows a hate symbol was spray
painted on the backside of the synagogue
someone spray-painted graffiti on a
cargo container about a block away
hours earlier a man was seen on video
kicking out the side window of a
synagogue in lincolnwood
unclear if the incidents are related and
uh alderwoman deborah silverstein said
vandalism was discovered at several
local jewish institutions and businesses
we want to make sure we stay on top of
this because unfortunately
that i say this with peace and love
too many
of my progressive brethren brothers and
sisters
um are not keyed in to the anti-semitism
they write it off with some very typical
sort of phylo-semitic tropes that i've
talked about before
and um
i don't i don't want to see that
so we're we're going to stay on top of
this whatever other shows do i can't
tell you but we're going to be staying
on top of this
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
um before i play today's voicemail uh if
anyone in the audience works for rivien
the electric car
maker
uh
please get in touch info at
davidpakman.com we have uh we have an
idea we'd like to talk to someone from
from rivien about
uh so if you work at rivian the electric
car manufacturer info davidpakman.com
here's a voicemail at 2192 david p
that really doesn't make a lot of sense
to me it's one of these where someone is
projecting onto me something
i guess from somewhere else this time
about dr fauci take a listen to this
david i'm not really sure why you're
still cheerleading anthony fauci at this
point it's pretty clear from all the
news coming out recently that the man is
a liar and a proven liar he clearly knew
that this virus came from more than just
a natural means
look into the emails released
they're real
i think he should be fired and he should
be ashamed of himself
uh he was never a very good person at
his position dealing with epidemics or
pandemics so listen first of all
nothing has been proven
about the origins of the virus other
than what we currently know which is it
seems to have come from animals
and jumped to humans once if and when we
have proof of something other than that
i will talk about it in terms of
cheerleading anthony fauci i don't know
that you've really seen my show i don't
really care about dr fauci as an
individual what i do know is that the
smear campaigns against him and his
motives
are not based in uh evidence or fact and
i am a cheerleader for the best
empirical knowledge that we have at the
time that's what you can always count on
on this program
what do we know
based on actual studies right now
that's what you are going to get from me
not cheerleading of individuals or
anything like it we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the joe rogan response to the spotify
dustup we're going to talk about the
california universal health care bill
it's dead without even a vote
how we'll talk about it and we will also
talk about the fifth new york prosecutor
who is now declined to file sexual
harassment charges against the former
governor andrew cuomo all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com
get instant access and i will see you
there
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman